hey what's up my name is Samuel Leeds
and I just thought I'd shoot a video
just to talk a little bit about my
thoughts on the UK election results so
Boris Boris Johnson has been elected as
prime minister again so he's gonna be
going back to 10 Downing Street and
here's the thing right first I just want
to say this I think that I've been
really sad to see even on my own
Facebook group we've got like 25,000
property investors just to see the hate
man the hate just been going around
people you know on both sides on every
side people getting really angry you
know swear in custody new people you
know saying that the resort is gonna
ruin their lives listen here's a thing
you and I we create our own economy okay
so no matter who's in power you're
always going to be able to make money if
there's people in the country okay
making money which there is then it's
possible to make money the people that
make the rules are usually the same
people that make money in property so
first thing I just want to say is just
to get this whole you know oh if
Corbin's elected then it means that
we're all gonna be broke and it borrows
it but that's just not how it works
Jim Rohn says that the same wind blows
on us all it's not about the wind that
determines the destination it's the
setting of the sail so I wasn't worried
while everyone else was staying up all
night waiting to see who was going to be
in well I mean I did make a prediction I
predicted that Corbin would not get in I
actually put ten thousand pounds on that
I said give ten thousand pounds to a
charity person my back begins but here's
the thing it doesn't matter it doesn't
matter the Boris is in it wouldn't have
mattered because we create our own
economy I really really believe that so
all the energy that you might be putting
into caring about politics now listen
don't get me wrong as well I voted ok I
don't even know if I'm gonna say I vote
for because I don't think it matters I
don't think it matters I think it
matters that you vote because people
died for us to have freedom of rust
about our voice and first about to vote
but I tell you what if you put the same
energy into getting really worked up and
watching the news
and going on Facebook and being annoyed
and all the hate that you have towards
Boris Johnson or towards Corbin all that
energy if you just put that into your
own business you put that into making
money in property you put that into
being smart and trying to figure out
rather than I don't want this person to
be elected rather than saying that to
say if this person is elected how is
that going to affect the marketplace and
how can I be fluid with my strategy and
monetize off of that and make money if
you put your energy into thinking like
that then you'll get rich so no hey no
hate man so what do I think is gonna
happen I guess I do need to give a
little bit of an opinion first thing is
it doesn't matter who's in you can
always make money even if it gets to the
point where you can't let's say the
country goes communist which is never
gonna happen but let's say it's just
completely impossible you just can't
there's still ways around it let's let's
still believe me I know there's ways
around it
but Boris Bentham what's gonna happen
okay so Corbin did have quite a lot of
extreme views around property investment
and landlords such as you know tenants
right - by abolishing section 21 notices
to get rid of tenants there was there
was some really quite concerning
policies that jeremy corbyn was with
advocating and the fact that now now
boris has been very doing I think what's
gonna happen is rightly or wrongly
property investors buyers that was
scared to buy that will holding off
those and I'm not gonna buy in case you
know Corbett gets in and this happens
and that happens now there's a level of
confidence that have come in to property
investors I've already seen that amongst
my twenty five thousand members which is
gonna mean that buyers I like okay I can
start buying again now so so people are
going to start buying which is then
gonna push house prices up so house
prices I just dropped my I just drop my
shades to house prices are gonna go up
that's my prediction over the coming
months because there's a bit more
certainty in the market so that that's
going to happen I think it's a very good
time to buy because there's still a lot
of uncertainty see your unbreak set see
Boris that they gas out of the EU again
is that a good thing or a bad thing
something you just need to figure out
how you can set the sale right it's just
wind blows on us all so just got to set
the sail right as Jim Rohn would say so
Boris
we've brakes it they're still insurgency
happening so what I would say is make
the most off of that uncertainty while
people are a little bit open now
Boris is in what's gonna happen when's
brixey gonna happen is it gonna happen
next month it's gonna happen next year
what people don't know people are scared
and what people are scared that's when
you should be greedy there's more than
Buffett says so get greedy now while
people are still uncertain but I think
just we've having Boris in I think just
the fact that Jeremy Corbyn is is not
going to be Prime Minister house prices
are going to go up because that was
scaring a lot of people that was scaring
a lot of people so that's my thoughts I
don't think it matters in terms of who's
in who's out you can still make money
just take all the energy you have
towards being successful cheer each
other on support each other no hate man
no hate
I've lived to know your thoughts I've
looked into your views and opinions so
drop a comment below let me know by the
way right now I'm in Phuket while
everyone else has been worrying about
the election staying up all night I've
been in Phuket enjoying the sunshine but
I do care I do care about politics I do
care about our country but I'm just I'm
just not into hanging on hanging on
people and I'm certainly not into giving
control over anybody else I'm up me and
my family I'm not interesting oh if this
person gets in we're all doomed no we're
not doomed I'm gonna look after myself
I'm and look after my family regardless
of who's in power regardless of what the
government's doing what what who's in
power the education system listen the
whole system is out to keep you poor the
whole education system is there to make
you poor but guess what I'm not poor and
I wish to jubei take control and take
responsibility of your own life never
leave it to someone else
it's just an excuse man people people
are just going to blame Corbin or now
going to blame Boris will blame brakes
net as to why they're so broke truth is
it's got nothing to do with that it's
just an excuse so take responsibility of
your life get money
help people and know hey that's my
message today know hey so I've lived in
the thoughts comment comment your
thoughts below if you liked this video
smash that like button if you did like
the video if you hate on me that's fine
I love it when people hate on me because
it just helps the YouTube algorithms and
for everyone hater
you've helped 200 so I'm just going to
keep speaking truth I'm gonna keep
speaking my voice people are scared to
talk about politics scared to talk about
money scared to talk about how to make
money I don't want to they don't want
you to be competition they don't want
you to be wealthy they don't want you
know what you can be welfare guess what
my my incentive of doing these videos of
wearing my crash course is it's not to
make money I don't even get I don't even
get paid to train people like my
training business just looks after
itself and we any any money makes you
put it back into the business I get paid
off property I'll get paid off making
money in property that's how I get paid
I'm just not afraid to speak to speak
truth I love I love I love seeing other
people succeed your success is Mark
stand that's my that's my currency these
days that's my currency my currency is
seeing people succeed because honestly
rich people the elite they don't want
you to compete with them so they'd
rather you stay poor and then the
government and the banks and the
education system they'd rather you stay
employees why so that because then
you're controllable so it's a threat
being financially free me saying that
anyone and everyone can be financially
free if they follow this just don't bump
on bomb I said furet that's a dangerous
message even some of my success students
people that become successful become
financially free then is to tell me to
stop teaching just because they've made
it now and I'm like man that's not my
heart so I'm just going to keep speaking
truth over 2020 I hope you succeed if
you have already succeeded if you've
been on my courses you've been on my
training now you're financially free let
me know go on to winners on a Wednesday
calm and come come on to the channel
let's talk let me know your success is
multi John anyway peace out I want to
see some comments below I read every
single comment I read every single
comment thank you so much